[Music]
yeah what it is Sparky sweets again and
this week we reppin down south with the
killer Mockingbird by Harper Lee this
book focuses on three little homies by
the name of scout her crippled brother
Jim and some homeboy by the name of dill
now Scouts of Papas of righteous lawyer
with the badass name of Atticus since
then nothing doing Alabama scouting her
cooch spend the summer harassing a
nearby sudden named Boo Radley now ain't
nobody seen Boo Radley for years
scouting her crew tried to pass boo a
note to see if he wants to chill but
Atticus gets all crunk and tell them
kids I leave a brother B next day some
little punk steps to scout and
straight-up call Scouts daddy Atticus a
[ __ ] lover hmm turns out Atticus has
been hired to defend some ashy player
named Tom Robinson who has been accused
of raping the daughter of a shady cat
named Bob Ewell at the trial my boy
Atticus spit slag game up in that
courtroom in fact he discovered it was
used daughter that was putting the moves
on time turns out she wanted some of
that dark chocolate no I mean I have to
see this daughter making advances on her
brother Mr Ewell smack that [ __ ] I've
robbed while time peace down but since
we talking about Alabama here don't
white folks convict him anyway why cuz
he black dad honky you'll be pissed that
Atticus made him look like a fool up in
court
so Halloween night heels down was too
much of that juice and gets the drop on
Jimmy scalp just we're here bout to
rough up my girl-scout crazy cracker Boo
Radley comes in out of nowhere and
shakes that fool oh he dead sick and
tired of his stupid lip the time
authorities decide that y'all got too
drunk and fell on his night boo gets off
scot-free
why cuz I seen him like my Girl Scout
says we'll be like shooting a
mockingbird
now you all know [ __ ] about this title
and so you read this head quote on page
90 mockingbirds don't do one thing but
make music for us to enjoy that's why
it's a sin to kill a mockingbird
only a jive ass fool would bother
capping a Mockingbird cuz all them
[ __ ] do is just drop next-level beats
for your enjoyment so what my girl
Harper trying to say is that rap no boo
radley
when do no good it only read the hood of
one more true blue player they're
already the [ __ ] up once my convicting
time so they ain't bout to pop another
mockingbird now this book right here is
a straight-up criticism of the South
during the Depression the courts the
schools the church all of them run by
crooked ass crackers now when we first
meet Scout she's sporting our that
southern racism and ignorance but after
kicking it with boo and Tom Robb she
matures and starts keeping it real this
brings me to one of the central themes
of this [ __ ] learning valuable lessons
by being exposed to people of difference
by hanging with the crazy cracker like
Boo Radley and the righteous black man
like T Robinson Scout has one of them
paradigm-shifting moments playing she
learns that these homies just be trying
to hustle like anybody else yo check it
Jim's crippled dance is a metaphor for
America's jacked-up justice system Jim
[ __ ] up it's also young be one of them
select the keys for a country that was
born with backwards ideals now that's my
Hill but it gonna leave a disabling scar
on the nation and ain't no amount of
cocoa butter gonna make that [ __ ] go
away
yo thanks for watching thug notes tune
in next week clown
you
[Music]